the White House is designating North
Korea's a state sponsor of terrorism
South Korea welcomed President Trump's
new move to pressure North Korean leader
Kim jong-un and said it will contribute
to peaceful denuclearization China says
that more could be done Margaret Brennan
is at the White House with the latest on
this story Margaret good morning good
morning it has been more than 60 days
since North Korea launched a missile and
this designation by the Trump
administration is potentially
provocative and it could test just how
much pressure Kim jong-un will take
before he agrees to negotiate the United
States is designating North Korea as a
state sponsor of terrorism President
Trump said putting North Korea back on
the terror blacklist was part of his
maximum pressure campaign to isolate kim
jeong-hoon in addition to threatening
the world by nuclear devastation North
Korea has repeatedly supported acts of
international terrorism including
assassinations on foreign soil
specifically one state-sponsored murder
that of leader Kim jong-un's
half-brother earlier this year his
killing was caught on security cameras
as two woman's smeared VX nerve agent on
his face at a Malaysian airport as we
take this action today our thoughts
turned to otto warmbier wonderful young
man the president also cited the case of
american otto warmbier a college student
who died following abuse in a North
Korean labor camp but the administration
provided no proof of North Korean
support for terrorist groups a legal
standard for other countries on the
blacklist like Syria and Iran
this designation allows the u.s. to
impose more sanctions on North Korea
already the world's most sanctioned
regime the practical effects may be
limited but we hopefully were closing
off a few loopholes but Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson admitted it is
largely symbolic the North Koreans have
demonstrated in the past they have an
enormous capacity to withstand a lot
they'll make their people pay later
today the Treasury Department will make
public what those new sanctions are
going to look like
also Norah we have learned that
President Trump and Russia's Vladimir
Putin plan to speak this morning a day
after Putin meant was met with Syrian
dictator Bashar al-assad the US and
Russia have been talking about a
political transition to end the war in
Syria all right Margaret thank you so
much